immer mehr hotspots und striktere regeln
die menschen in deutschland bekommen die
korona pandemie wieder deutlicher zu
spüren
prozess um cyberbunker weil die server
für kriminelle geschäfte betrieben haben
müssen sich acht männer vor gericht
verantworten und rassistische
anfeindungen gegen bvb nachwuchs der
künftige bundesliga-profi yussuf amoco
ziel übler beleidigungen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem montag norbert lehmann ist auch
wieder dabei für den sport ein wunder
von mir
wir beginnen mit der korona lage da
macht nicht nur der drastische anstieg
der neuinfektionen sorgen sondern auch
ihre verteilung es sind jetzt nicht mehr
nur vereinzelte ausbrüche auf
schlachthöfen oder bei familienfeiern
sondern das virus verbreitet sich immer
flächiger und das erschwert die suche
nach dem infektionsherd ganz gewaltig
mittlerweile gelten in deutschland wegen
der hohen infektionszahlen schon mehr
als 100 landkreise als risikogebiet fast
90 weitere kreise erreichen die
zweithöchste warnstufe
immer mehr regionen verschaffen ihre
maßnahmen christoph distel berichtet
delmenhorst dem norden hat ein problem
es gab nicht dass eine corona
großereignis und trotzdem 223 neue fälle
in einer woche auf 100.000 einwohner dem
virus hinterher telefonieren geht da
nicht mehr zu diffus die lage der
bürgermeister will aber hart
durchgreifen wo es noch geht etwa bei
den gaststätten die alles etwas zu
locker sehen werden und das werden wir
natürlich in einem ordentlichen
verfahren tun
dann sollen die aufwertung das muss
spiel war sein
einige leute erreicht du nur über das
portemonnaie einen strengen regelkatalog
hat sich die stadt gegeben vielleicht
eine blaupause für weitere hotspots
anderswo masken pflichtete auch draußen
wo es eng wird etwa in der fußgängerzone
sperrstunde für die gastronomie ab 23
uhr und bei privaten feiern maximal zehn
personen in berchtesgaden ganz im süden
haben sie sogar 252 neue fälle ländlich
ruhig eigentlich aber wieder einmal wird
von einer party gemunkelt und ein
österreichischer hotspot ist auch nicht
weit radikal herunterfahren will sich
der ort jetzt die bewohner nur noch mit
triftigen grund aus der eigenen wohnung
lassen die schulen schließen ein großer
schuss vor den bug das was wir heute mit
dieser ausgangs beschränkung für morgen
bestimmen wird für die nächsten 14 tage
vorerst gelten im ganzen land steigen
die zahlen im wochenschnitt jetzt auf
6050 ansteckungen entsprechend sieht es
in den großen innenstädten aus hier etwa
frankfurt während hamburg jetzt eine
instanz von über 50 fällen meldet ist
man am main schon über 100 entsprechend
masken wohin man sieht sinnvoll findet
dass der ärztepräsident mahnt aber auch
bitte realistisch und gleichzeitig
besonnen bleiben
wir sollten das auch zur kenntnis nehmen
und sollten lernen uns darauf einrichten
in den nächsten monaten mit diesem virus
oder auch noch längere zeit tatsächlich
in einer vernünftigen praktikablen
koexistenz uns einzurichten
die kanzlerin erinnert derweil an diese
seite der pandemie die integration in
deutschland leide unter corona und die
betroffenen ganz besonders wir wissen
dass gerade menschen mit
migrationshintergrund oft in berufen
arbeiten die als erste unter druck
geraten vielleicht und deshalb gilt der
aufgabe des zusammenhalts der
gesellschaft und dazu gehört für mich
integration
unser besonderes augenmerk wohl die
passende lösung für herbst und winter
niemanden in diesen tagen aus dem blick
verlieren was in der korona krise
beschlossen wurde das war bisher fast
ausschließlich sache der regierung und
der bundesländer
die runden der ministerpräsidentinnen
und ministerpräsidenten bei der
kanzlerin legten die marschroute fest
das passt einigen politikern aus
koalition und opposition nicht mehr
sie fordern jetzt dass die parlamente in
bund und ländern stärker einbezogen
werden
patrizia wiedemeier es waren in den
letzten monaten immer wieder die
ministerpräsidentin und präsidentinnen
die zusammen mit der kanzlerin neue
maßnahmen beschlossen haben sich oft
uneins waren oft keine gemeinsame linie
gefunden haben
markus söder bis vor kurzem vorsitzender
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz beklagt
nun die uneinigkeit fordert heute dass
kompetenzen von den ländern auf den bund
übertragen werden
wir müssen überlegen wie wir mehr
einheitlichkeit in deutschland erreichen
können und zwar durch ein gesetz und
dieses gesetz ist das jetzt im
infektionsschutzgesetz in deutschland
und ist glaube ich muss einige
kompetenzen von den ländern an den bund
übertragen bekommen damit einheitliche
regelungen sind übrigens auch deswegen
wir können nicht auf dauer die gesamte
wirksamkeit der kroner maßnahmen nur der
verwaltungsgerichtsbarkeit vergeben
der bundestag hatte im märz das
infektionsschutzgesetz erweitert damit
der regierung zusätzliche befugnisse
eingeräumt allerdings befristet auf ein
jahr
die umsetzung der maßnahmen ist dann
sache der länder vertreter aller
parteien im bundestag fordern jetzt aber
mehr mitsprache und häufigere debatten
im bundestag und bundesrat kriterien
müssen bundeseinheitlich sein sie müssen
nachvollziehbar sein und hier müssen
verständlich sein
ich kann nicht mehr sehen dass die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz diese rolle
erfüllen kann
herr sparen vollzieht beschlüsse ich
sage mal aus der kaffeerunde bei frau
merkel unsere verfassung sieht eine
runde der ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundeskanzlerin als verfassungsgebende
oder gesetzgeberisches organ nicht vor
das macht alleine der deutsche bundestag
das parlament ist die erste gewalt im
staate regierung dürfen nur aufgrund von
gesetzen tätig werden die
parlamentarische erzielt worden sind wir
brauchen auch wieder eine diskussion in
parlamenten damit die menschen
nachvollziehen können welche maßnahmen
sinnvoll nicht sinnvoll sind wie man zur
entscheidung gekommen ist vor allem
gewähren damit fehler familien das ist
das entscheidende
auch bundestagspräsident wolfgang
schäuble hat sich heute schriftlich an
die abgeordneten gewandt und angemahnt
dass der bundestag seine rolle als
gesetzgeber und öffentliches forum
deutlich machen muss um den eindruck zu
vermeiden pandemie bekämpfung sei
ausschließlich sache von exekutive und
judikative mehr debatten also im
parlament mehr informationen durch die
bundesregierung mehr transparenz nur
dann könne die akzeptanz in der
bevölkerung für die korona maßnahmen
gewährleistet werden wenn die schulen
trotz steigender corona zahlen offen
bleiben sollen dann müssen sich schüler
wie lehrer warm anziehen
das zeigte sich heute am ersten schultag
nach den herbstferien der neben abstands
und hygieneregeln entlüften als das
beste mittel
im kampf gegen das virus auch wenn es
kalt wird man bernd berichtet aus
schleswig-holstein noch drei sekunden
bis zum lüften
ein schüler der klasse 4b der
grundschule kiel russee muss aufpassen
dass alle 20 minuten die fenster
geöffnet werden mit schulbeginn in
schleswig holstein ist das
vorgeschrieben genauso wie das
durchgängige lüften in den pausen und
die meisten eltern haben den acht decken
mit wir geben es ist wichtig im extrem
kalt drinnen aber man muss jetzt etwas
dickere sachen anziehen deswegen finde
ich das eigentlich gut dass man auch
durchleuchtet auch wenn corona schon für
den herbst legen hat klassenlehrerin
julia schmidt hollenberg die 27 kinder
vorbereitet vorsorglich wärmere kleidung
und decken doch eltern befürchten mehr
infekte mehr erkältungen und die
lehrerin sorgt sich wie es weitergeht
mit corona im herbst jetzt kommt nochmal
hinzu dass man es irgendwie nicht
richtig einschätzen kann wie endet das
ganze dann oder muss die klasse in
quarantäne und wie wird der schulalltag
stattfinden weil man schon gemerkt hat
dass das lernen in der gemeinschaft
einfach so wichtig ist für die kinder
für die grundschule im norden gilt
masken pflicht auf dem schulhof und den
gängen nicht im unterricht ab der
fünften klasse in den weiterführenden
schulen gilt aber eine 14-tägige masken
pflicht sind der festen überzeugung dass
gerade bei den älteren schülerinnen und
schülern ist wichtig ist dass sie jetzt
die nächsten zwei wochen maske tragen
damit die infektionszahlen weiter
niedrig gehalten werden können
unterricht in der grundschule kiel
russee auf den ersten blick sieht es aus
wie immer doch auch hier hat sich
einiges durch strengere corona maßnahmen
verändert immer mehr corona fälle und
wieder mehr menschen mit masken in
unserer heute erklärt ein experte für
körpersprache wie reden wir am besten
miteinander wenn das halbe gesicht
verdeckt ist jetzt zur corona lage
international weltweit haben sich
inzwischen 40 millionen menschen
angesteckt beispiel russland allein in
moskau waren es mehr als 5000 fälle
innerhalb eines tages
alarmierende zahlen auch in
großbritannien so wales
bild ab freitag eine weitreichende
ausgangssperre
der lock down wird scharf und tief sagt
der ministerpräsident auch polen rechnet
mit rasant steigenden patientenzahlen
das nationalstadion in warschau soll zum
notlazarett werden
in österreich hat regierungschef kurz
verkündet dass die teilnehmerzahlen bei
veranstaltungen weiter
zusammengestrichen werden
nach frankreich ein geschichtslehrer
wird auf offener straße enthauptet
nachdem er im unterricht
mohammed-karikaturen behandelt hat
dieser anschlag am freitag in paris
hinterlässt tiefe bestürzung die
französische regierung will jetzt
stärker gegen radikalen islamismus
vorgehen
der mutmaßliche täter hatte noch im
internet mit seinem verbrechen geprahlt
bevor er von der polizei erschossen
wurde
aus paris tunis weiter in hörsälen
überall im land und auf den straßen
gedachten heute tausende des ermordeten
lehrer samuel partie wie schon am
wochenende die französische republik
sieht mehr als einen einzelfall
in die trauer mischt sich wut
die nation ist in gefahr ihre werte
werden attackiert die regierung handelt
nicht genug man muss etwas tun
leider wurde samuel partie allein
gelassen und wurde nicht unterstützt
[Musik]
partie hatte im unterricht die mohammed
karikaturen und die meinungsfreiheit
behandelt ein 18 jähriger brachte ihn um
der vater eines schülers hatte partie
zuvor gedroht und gemeinsam mit einem
bekannten islamisten seine entlassung
gefordert
beide sitzen nun in untersuchungshaft
nach der sitzung des verteidigungsrates
kündigte der innenminister im radio ein
hartes vorgehen gegen islamisten an
durchsuchungen festnahmen
die individuen haben nicht unbedingt mit
der tat zu tun aber wir senden eine
klare botschaft keine minute ruhe für
die feinde der republik kritiker werfen
der regierung schon länger vor nicht
genug gegen den druck von islamisten auf
schulen zu unternehmen
der terrorismus ist eine kriegserklärung
er muss mit kriegsrecht beantwortet
werden der staat muss sich wieder
bewaffnen moralisch und materiell
präsident makro kondolierte den
angehörigen des opfers für den mittwoch
ist eine nationale gedenkfeier
angekündigt
im tarifkonflikt im öffentlichen dienst
von bund und kommunen hat sich
innenminister seehofer zu wort gemeldet
er sehe vor der dritten
verhandlungsrunde am donnerstag durchaus
potenzial sich zu einigen
die gewerkschaften machen unterdessen
weiter druck mit warnstreiks in
nordrhein westfalen beispielsweise
konnten viele pendler heute weder bus
noch bahn nutzen
die gewerkschaften fordern bei einer
einjährigen laufzeit eine lohnsteigerung
von 4,8 prozent die arbeitgeber bieten
3,5 prozent mehr über drei jahre ganz
anderes thema jetzt wir blicken an die
mosel nach traben-trarbach
da gibt es nicht nur moose romantik und
steile weinberge sondern auch ein relikt
des kalten krieges einen bundeswehr
bunker mit 5000 quadratmetern fläche den
hatte ein investor gekauft und mit
computern voll gepackt sein service
verschlüsselte digitale infrastruktur
für den online-handel mit allem was
verboten ist waffen etwa oder drogen
jetzt hat der prozess gegen die
betreiber begonnen susanne gelhard
berichtet in diesem ehemaligen
bundeswehr bunker in traben trarbach
sollen cyberkriminelle sechs jahre lang
ihre millionenschweren geschäfte im
darknet betrieben haben
nach einem spektakulären zugriff letztes
jahr ein spektakulärer prozess angeklagt
sind vier niederländer drei deutsche ein
bulgare
zum einen sollen die angeklagten eine
kriminelle vereinigung gebildet haben
zum anderen sollen sie beihilfe
geleistet haben zu den knapp 250.000
straftaten waffen- und drogenhandel
kinderpornografie cyberangriffe dafür
sollen die angeklagten ihren kunden
wissentlich web seiten gehostet also
gegen entgelt zur verfügung gestellt
haben
bei dem song kann muss man jetzt erstmal
nachweisen dass der betreiber
tatsächlich wusste dass da illegale
dinge stattgefunden haben dann muss man
natürlich auch nachweisen dass
tatsächlich illegale dinge drauf sind
auf diesen servern die von dort aus
betrieben wurden über fünf etagen tief
wurden mehr als 400 server
sichergestellt fünf jahre wurde verdeckt
ermittelt
wir haben zwei petabyte an daten
sichergestellt das entspricht circa zwei
millionen gigabyte an daten und wenn man
diese daten auf cds brennen würde und
die übereinander stapelt wird man eine
höhe von circa 8000 metern erreichen
was genau ist dem bunker gelaufen die
staatsanwaltschaft ist sich sicher dass
sie für einen schuldspruch genug beweise
hat wenn newsmeldung kamen also
meldungen dazu dass kriminelle seite
gepostet werden
dann wird ein legaler hoster diese seite
vom netz nehmen dass wir bei unseren
theatern gerade nicht so ein mammut
verfahren soll jetzt aufklärung bringen
bis ende kommenden jahres wird es
mindestens dauern
in thailand brodelt es seit wochen vor
allem junge leute gehen in massen auf
die straße und demonstrieren für mehr
demokratie und gegen die regierung
der ehemalige militärchef prayuth
chan-ocha ist seit einem militärputsch
2014 an der macht der zorn der
demonstranten richtet sich aber auch
gegen die monarchie und gegen könig maha
vajiralongkorn er sitzt seit vier jahren
auf dem thron normen odenthal gerichtet
tag für tag sammeln sie sich tag für tag
werden es mehr
thailands jugend ist auf der straße
fordert eine neue regierung weniger
macht für das militär und das braucht
besonders viel mut weniger macht für die
monarchie majestätsbeleidigung wird hart
bestraft in diesem land aber das
schreckt sie nicht
ich bin hier und ich bleibe egal was
kommt ich habe keine angst wir stehen
das durch
ich will für die demokratie kämpfen das
ist unserer zeit unsere chance wir sind
viele und wir fürchten uns nicht wir
sind friedlich gewalt geht nur von der
polizei aus ob das so ist wer provoziert
wer reagiert kaum zu beurteilen aber es
geht hoch her immer wieder der
ausnahmezustand ist verhängt ein
versammlungsverbot gilt und wird
missachtet das regime das seine macht
aufs militär stützt reagiert gereizt
es ist die pflicht der regierung die
monarchie zu beschützen dass es die
pflicht jedes thailändischen bürgers
davon weichen wir nicht ab und wir
fordern dass die demonstranten friedlich
bleiben der monarch erlebt die unruhen
aus nächster nähe er ist im land was
eine echte nachricht ist weil der könig
sonst lieber im fernen bayern weilt
zwischen desinteresse am und
unterdrückung des volkes so erscheint
der jugend seine herrschaft das bringt
sie zum tabubruch zu öffentlichen kritik
lange schien das undenkbar wohin das nun
führt kann heute keiner sagen aber es
steht viel auf dem spiel für alle in
thailand wir sind beim sport da zeigten
sich am wochenende leider wieder die
hässlichen seiten des fußballs norberts
in form von rassistischen anfeindungen
gegen ein teenager kann man wohl sagen
betroffen ist der dortmunder
nachwuchsspieler joseph & co
beim 3 2 gegen des bvb beim u19 derby
gegen schalke 04 wurde der 15-jährige
übelst beleidigt mukoko hatte alle drei
treffer erzielt schalke hat sich
inzwischen beim bvb entschuldigt
ein kapitel auf das schalke
sportvorstand jochen schneider gerne
verzichtet hätte zum alles auf schalke
keine seltenheit ist
im februar dieses jahres trifft das den
berliner turnerriege er wird mit
affenlauten beleidigt jetzt im fokus der
anfeindungen dortmund ausnahmetalent
mukoko im november wird der 16 darf dann
bundesliga und sogar champions league
spielen bei den 19 jährigen überragt er
mit seiner treffsicherheit die ihn
jedoch nicht vor anfeindungen schützt
auch wenn der dfb ermittelt kommt das
stärkste statement wohl von ihm selbst
ich bin stolz mit dieser hautfarbe
geboren worden zu sein und werde immer
stolz sein
ein klares statement gegen hass und
rassismus der dfb bewirbt sich zusammen
mit belgien und den niederlanden für die
austragung der frauenfußball-wm 2027 das
deutsche gesicht der bewerbung ex
bundestrainer silvia neid
ich glaube es würde wieder so ein
richtiger boom werden wir sind ja auch
in deutschland richtiges
fußballverrücktes land und das jetzt
hier was wir jetzt machen wenn es
klappen sollte mit drei nationen dass
wir natürlich hervorragend zur champions
league morgen geht schon wieder los mit
der gruppenphase dortmund tritt bei
lazio rom an
ja und leipzig zu hause gegen den
türkischen meister besiktas istanbul er
braucht in der schweren gruppe h
unbedingt einen sieg nur 63 tage nach
dem unglücklichen halbfinal aus gegen
paris möchten die männer von julian
nagelsmann wieder so jubeln wie zuletzt
in der bundesliga gegen einen gegner der
sportliche aufs und ups in kürzester
zeit erlebt hat
top-spiele bis jetzt gemacht mit viel
engagement mit viel power mit viel lust
und keine sekunde gab es irgendwie mal
bedenken dass wir nicht gewinnen wollen
nationalspieler klostermann wird nicht
spielen können wegen knieproblemen das
werden auch kapitän sabitzer und konrad
laimer fehlen
das geht es erstmal darum die
gruppenphase so zu gestalten dass wir
die ersten zwei kommen dass unser ziel
neben gegner wie paris und manunited
dürfte basak noch die einfachste aufgabe
in gruppe h sein theaters h stiefel auch
für hammer gruppe echt starke geht
drückt mir die daumen
fehlt noch der blick aufs wetter die
mützen können erstmal wieder in den
schrank zurück denn in den nächsten
tagen wird es wieder wärmer mehr dazu
hat gleich festen termin im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn spricht
claus kleber mit fdp-parteichef lindner
wir danken für ihr interesse wünschen
ihnen noch einen schönen abend und sagen
wenn sie mal auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schirm gehabt und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der
tiefdruckkomplex im westen europas
beziehungsweise auf dem atlantik bleibt
uns erhalten und so gelangt aus dem
südwesten europas warme luft bis nach
deutschland und die temperaturen steigen
deutlich über die 20 grad marke in der
nacht bildet sich bei hohem luftdruck
erst einmal nebel an donau main und
rhein je weiter man nach norden schaut
desto mehr wolken sind dabei insgesamt
bleibt es trocken und am kältesten wird
es wie immer dort wo die wolken fehlen
mit minus 1 grad an den alpen hier
leichter frost zum beispiel und ganz im
westen im rheinland mit acht grad plus
morgen vormittag im süden noch nebel der
löst sich allmählich auf von westen her
verdichtet sich die bewölkung und dann
zum nachmittag kommt hier regen auf und
zwar nördlich der mittelgebirge bis zur
nordsee aber teils auch bis zur ostsee
rüber ansonsten sonnige abschnitte bei
temperaturen bis 18 teils 19 grad im
südwesten deutschlands und 11 grad an
der ostsee die kommenden tage bringen
uns noch wärmeres wetter mittwoch bis 22
grad im nordwesten sturm und schauer und
donnerstag noch einmal bis 23 grad warm
freitag nur noch bis 18 grad
einen schönen abend